hello welcome back to gam spots coverage
of e323 2013 God no I've entered a Time
Warp I don't know when we are is this
2015 2014 I know someone who know it'll
be Shan Ram jaing from NHL which NHL is
coming out this year NHL 15's coming up
oh so it's 2015 201 so we're 2015
perfect EA E3 2014 here Sean pleasure to
have you here sir NHL this is a a game
that I loved on the Genesis played a bit
on back the day I spent all last night
on Twitter talking to Gamespot fans
about what they want out of this game so
I've got a buch of questions from those
folks a couple for myself as well but
just give us the overview of what you
guys are doing this year that was
different than last year because sports
games EA it's always an edior process
yes yeah we were literally really
excited to be on the new consoles for
the first time with NHL 15 U we
literally changed everything Levering
the power of the consoles from brand new
player models um rebuilding them from
the ground up we have brand new physics
in the game new multiplayer physics 12
players in physics any one time brand
new Puck physics as well built from the
ground up brand new NBC presentation
packageing your game so what you see on
TV is what you're going to see in our
game this year brand new commentators
our fans have been asking for new
commentators for a long time now so we
have doc Emer Edy oldi and raay for all
run done in a way that's never been seen
before in the sports games and it's
about bringing that Arena to life as
well and replicating what you see on TV
and when you go to the hockey rings that
you know all that detail within each one
of the Arenas and over 9,000 new crowd
models as well so really focus on the
atmosphere as well so that crowd stuff I
think is is that do you guys work with
other teams in that respect because I
know FIFA 14 was uh for nextg when they
released that earlier this year that was
one of those games uh that sort of
dipped into that new crowd stuff do you
guys work with other teams yeah that's
one of the you know one of the real
benefits of being part of EA Sports
we're able to you know leverage
everything going on around us um with
FIFA and Madden company coming out on on
the Next Generation consoles before us
we're able to take all their learnings
take all their technology bring it over
to NHL um we just had UFC up here we
work very closely with the UFC team on
the same floor as part of the same
business unit we share l lot of assets a
lot of the Great Stuff a lot of the
great visuals you see in NHL um are
taken from USC brought over and turned
into hockey so lots of sharing it just
makes like you know we come out every
single year with the game and we try and
push and get as much stuff in there as
we can every single year so the more
that we can share the more that we can
borrow the more that we can learn from
each other the better the games are
going to be for our fans so what's it
like trying to make hockey is a pretty
good game to try and make into a video
game because let's be honest like the
moment to moment action is pretty
entertaining like you can score at any
stage it seems breakaways and then the
just the physicality of that sport uh
what's it like trying to make a game
that is um a simulator but is also fun
and captures that Essence yeah it's a
fine balance obviously you we want to be
true to sport as much as we can but we
have to take some Liberties and
understand it is a game that we're
making we're making an entertainment
product and and we always want to make
authentic hockey but people's definition
of authentic is what differs if you're a
casual hockey fan you want to have lots
of goal scoring you want to have lots of
big hits you want to have lots of fights
if you're a hardcore hockey fan you want
to see every little detail in the game
from the from the jerseys moving with
the cloth to guys not getting knocked
over all the time to make have to set up
in the offensive zone or dump and Chase
to get the puck back and just that level
of detail really focusing on offensive
and defensive AI so we're looking at the
trailer you guys showed at the EA press
conference on Monday as well and what
were you trying to get across in this
trailer uh just what the power of next
gen brings to our game this year and you
know the V the visuals that you see here
when we talk about leveraging technology
from USC uh for the dynamic cloth in
there we actually rebuilt our player
model from the ground up this year so
taking we modeled the body we not
modeled the equipment on top of that
body and then using some technology for
the fashion industry dropped the Jersey
over top of that so you're seeing cloth
game for the first time on all the
players here you see some multiplayer
Collision physics here some of the new
pieces for gam playay again in the past
our physics our fans have loved the
physics we've had in the game this year
it was about going from two players
being in physics to all 12 players
having the ability to get in physics
you're watching the playoffs right now
and there's scrambles crazy scrambles
desperation plays going all the time
pups in front of the net pups in the
goal crease um and that's what we want
to have in nhel 15 with the physics that
we have in well the king the kings could
win the Stanley Cup on Friday uh so do
you expect do you guys have Riot physics
because I think that might be something
we see outside at thec in about 48 Hours
time hopefully hope hopefully the Kings
I'm a king fan so Hopey the Kings win
hopefully you don't see the riot piece
though H it always comes up when we talk
about these games obviously you guys
have the uh the the the fighting it's
it's part of uh hockey culture I guess
um how much did you guys work with the
UFC guys on on that sort of stuff not
not not too much on the funny mechanics
itself we we invested pretty heavily in
NH shell 14 or fighting engine and the
thing about fighting is it's part of the
sport um and there's a whole game within
the game on the ice in The Real L goes
with fighting you want to go throw a hit
on a big Superstar you can expect one of
their tough guys to come over and CH to
fight so there's the whole code that
goes with fighting and for us we just
trying to replicate that code in our
game and our fans love fighting so we
put the fighting in there for them
that's crazy how much of the like that
that sort of like that pageantry do you
have in a because whenever I watch
hockey and I it's one of those sports
that I S like one of the last American
sport I need to I need to conquer um
there seems to be a lot of history in
pageantry like whenever you know hat
tricks happen like throwing the hats on
the ice H is it is it this the octopus
that get thrown out as well like how
much of that stuff do you do you put in
the game where do you draw the line
because there's so much of that like
tradition to pull from absolutely yeah
this year we really focus on the details
within each one of the Arenas this year
rebuilding them from the ground up if
you go to Madison Square Gardens you're
going to see you know the secondary
characters walking around the glass that
unique geometry they have where the
seats don't come all the way down um to
ice level oh wow um so really
replicating each one of the Arenas and
then focusing on our crowd we have over
9,000 unique crowd models in our game so
um bringing that crowd to life we have
the ability to um to to differentiate
the crowd so if you're a Montreal
Canadians or aano may police where the
team travels really well with their fans
and it's 50/50 if you go to a Montreal
game in Vancouver for example we can
have full control of the crowd or if
you're playing in Calgary we can have
that entire SE red in there as well
we've got the super fans in the game we
have that away team Super Fan that
annoying guy that everyone hates we've
got we've got people in the crowd taking
selfies not paying attention reacting
reacting late to the to the goal being
score got the bang banging on the wall
we we have the glass bangers in there
you have a fight break out in the corner
you'll see the glass bangers up and
getting into it so it's really you know
just bringing out all those little
details with the crowd and making that
crowd a big part of the atmosphere just
to bring that game to life awesome I
want to get into a couple of questions
uh that that I got I picked up last
night and if you have any yourself at
the moment Dan DWI on Twitter or if
you're in the Gamespot chat do Dan O DWI
on there as well apologies my surname is
hard to uh spell if you don't know it
already H Darcy Palmer asked H will
weather be adjustable for outdoor games
so actually will you have outdoor games
uh we got lots more we going to talk
about modes probably the next you know
six to8 weeks as we head up toward
towards launch so here3 which mostly on
gameplay presentation Okay cool so you
got to hold that question for watch this
space all right no worries H and also
yeah this A A lot of people are asking
this you going to maintain the NHL and
94 anniversary mode that you had um yeah
actually we talked yesterday about that
a little bit it's going to be in the
Xbox 360 and PS3 versions and then uh
still of the details of all the modes
for uh for the for the Next Generation
console game is still to come that came
around as well with with FIFA last year
there was a bunch of stuff that just
never made the cut H is it has trying to
get in that like the rescanning the the
player models adding in that crowd stuff
like at what stage do you just have to
say we have to leave out these features
because when an annualized franchise
surely time is of the essence and you
have to pick and choose yeah people
always ask us how well how do you come
up with new ideas every single year you
know where do the all all these ideas
come from the thing is our fans never
see the ideas that hit The Cutting Room
floor um you know we have limited time
resources we have a deadline we need to
hit every single year um so we need to
make some tough choices really on early
on in the project and what we do is we
go back and we re revisit those things
that we cut we say you know are they
still are they still relevant do they
still make sense do fans still want this
based on the feedback we're getting
listen to The Fan feedback as well see
what they're asking for so we start to
build it that into our plans and I feel
you know it's our job as producers as a
design team production team to always
think about new ways to kind of raise
the bar things that our fans aren't even
thinking of that's possible and try and
deliver those experiences well so that's
where those three things come from the
three ideas three main places that new
ideas come from for our games is that a
challenge then when you add in any
feature because then you're like oh God
we have to do this one every single year
or like like is that a worry I don't
think I don't think it's a worry cuz I
think we want to get it out there and we
want to make it awesome when we put it
out there and then get the feedbacks and
start to tweak it so it's usually not
massive overhauls we need to make year
after year if it's we delivered it
properly the first time and you know we
do lots of early testing with our games
these days bring people in get their
early feedback we have an idea and we
have an idea we think it's going to you
know meet the needs of our fans but we
don't actually know until we give it to
them get them play get that feedback so
we can adjust it so no longer is it
let's get our ideas into the game put it
out there and see what happens and try
and fix it the next year we have people
coming in early on in the process giving
us feedback back on it cool H got a
couple more questions here soda says in
14 uh the player couldn't control the
goalie uh has that mechanic changed or
evolved at all in 15 uh we're going to
get we're going to get to a lot of the
control mechanics later on as well all
right yeah um so I I will I can't tell
you though with our new our Superstar
deaking system it's something that we
continue to improve on every single year
um and this year because we can do more
we can put more animations there we've
pretty much overhauled all the
animations in our deaking system uh we
have new stri de and we have upper and
lower body separation as well which
gives a whole new level of control to
the players themselves never seen before
what that means is you can be gliding
you can be turning um and you can do tow
drags out of it you can basically take
the puck to placees you couldn't before
get through spaces you couldn't just
really giving you more tools as a gamer
to have success in our game what a bit
the the new Puck uh physics as well um I
don't want to keep harping back to FIFA
but it is a touchstone I have I remember
when they brought that in I think it was
maybe two years ago it really did change
up they it didn't feel like it was stuck
to you anymore H how is the new Puck
physics going to change between 14 and
15 yeah it's fundamentally changed our
gameplay experience it's really amazing
we've actually rebuilt from the ground
we actually have a guy who worked on the
Hadron Collider in Geneva switzland
where they really smash parles together
create black hole so we brought him over
uh he brought we brought him over to
work on our Puck physics uh and the
results are amazing CU now the puck is
going plac the puck hasn't gone before
because it's literally just doing what
physics would do U so it's going to hit
the goalie you know shots are going
through the goalie squeaking through
goalies it's hitting the goalie hitting
the cloth on the goalie then hitting
that equipment that we model underneath
the goalie and then based on the angle
of the puck and the speed it's going um
it's squeaking through places it hasn't
before and so the behavior you know for
fans a player game every single year um
the Puck's going to be doing things
you've never seen the puck do before
it's it's really really amazing from the
pucks rolling and turning on the ice to
um just amazing goals amazing bounces
just everything just looks that much
more realistic because of the realistic
Puck physics excellent uh Gregory Craven
asks H will difficulty sliders and third
jerseys be available at launch uh
difficulty sliders yeah definitely um
that's part of the game we want to you
know give our fans the ability to
customize the experience as much as
possible um THS jerseys uh we'll talk
about that later on you got to get those
highr scans all your jerseys as well is
that going to be a problem then with the
Arenas because I know that was an issue
with when the FIFA made the transition
to nextg was that because of the Meed
detail that's required for the new
Arenas that maybe the past gen version
has more versions than the next gen
version are you guys having that issue
as well um not so much I mean for us
we're just giving we're we're able to
give so much more this year I mean we
had a couple we had a couple semi
generic Arenas in gen 3 uh and this year
we're able to model out pretty much
every single arena in the NHL and try
and nail every detail we have a very
very passionate development team in
Vancouver who are um not only developers
of the game but consumers of the game
those guys um bring it every single day
and just want to have every single
detail correct and when we have to kind
of shut things down and and say you know
what we just we don't have time to
squeeze out one more thing and like come
on just I'll work all night to get that
in all right so that's how we get to all
those details no worries Sean R ja
saying absolutely pleasure to have you
here sir H for the folks watching at
home NHL 15 for current gen we can now
say and P gen when is it out when can
people finally get a hold of September
9th September 9th all right sounds like
you got a bit more work to do absolutely
on back